bonjour bonsoir à tous j'espère que vous
allez bien au passage bonne année bonne
anniversaire bord en confinement moi je
viens juste de déménager donc décor un
peu à l'arraché mais neutre et non pas
on n'est pas là pour parler des qu est
ce que vous êtes déjà monté dans une
voiture
c'est vrai et ça tombe bien parce que
justement aujourd'hui on va parler de la
voiture de la bagnole de la caisse du
tacot tu fais quoi avec les
illustrations la sérieux alors c'est
indéniable la voiture constitue un fait
de société majeur déjà par le simple
fait qu'elle fait partie intégrante de
nos vies en 2010 sur 100 kilomètres
effectués par les ménages 83 l'on était
en voiture
donc c'est pas étonnant qu'on voit des
voitures partout dans les séries dans
les films les clips
elles sont iconiser déifié sexualisé
roland barthes a fait de la citroën ds
la couverture de ces mythologies
modernes et on bouffe des pubs de pagnol
à longueur de journée qu'ils nous
vendent l'évasion la liberté le cul et
pas qu'un peu
et bien évidemment les sociologues se
sont intéressés à cet objet tellement
imbriquée dans nos vies qu'il existe un
mot en langue française pour désigner
les personnes sexuellement attirée par
les voitures
ça s'appelle la mécano philippe tueur à
vérifier même si c'est vrai c'est pas
spécifiquement réservée aux voitures ça
englobe aussi d'autres objets comme les
vélos ou les aéroplanes
allez les amphores tous avec moi c'est
parti la mécano philly c'est quand m
baiser des voitures venez on va bouger
un peu alors le livre de référence sur
le sujet c'est bas à tomber le livre de
référence sur le sujet c'est cette
petite sociologie de l'automobile de
pierre lannoy et yoann démoli dans cet
ouvrage
ils décrivent l'automobile comme un fait
social total alors un fait social total
c'est une expression qu'on doit au
sociologue marcel mauss je vous avais
déjà parlé dans ma précédente vidéo
alors lui il s'en servait pour parler du
don mais c'est à peu près la même idée
ici l'idée du fait social total c'est
qu'on est ici face à un élément qui
donne une signification globale à toute
une réalité sociale chatons il faut il
faut que tu arrêtes de jouer avec mon
micro
l'idée c'est qu'à travers la voiture on
va pouvoir explorer quasiment tous les
aspects de la société que soit l'âge le
genre les inégalités sociales
économiques culturelles et c'est
justement un petit peu le chemin que je
vous propose de parcourir avec moi
aujourd'hui à temps
ah oui
[Musique]
bon
bon déjà si on s'intéresse à la voiture
comme objet de consommation il faut
s'intéresser aussi un petit peu à la
façon dont elle s'est diffusée en date
la toute première voiture de 1885
lorsque le constructeur carl benz
commercialise le tricycle benz un
d'automne ce match mais on le considère
comme la première voiture parce que
c'est la première machine à fonctionner
avec un moteur à explosion
mais comme son nom l'indiqué c'est un
tricycle donc il n'a que trois roues et
pour illustrer sa sachez qu'il existe
toujours aujourd'hui certains modèles
qui roulent encore d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote derrière la création il faut
savoir que le perfectionniste carl benz
travail plus de dix ans sur sa machine
qui n'utilisent que quelques mètres dans
son allée pour l'attester entre de
bidouillage tant et si bien que sa femme
bertha benz qui est en fait son associé
et financent en grande partie le bouzin
se lasse du perfectionnisme de son mari
et le 12 août 1888
elle profite du fait qu'il est endormi
pour emprunter la machine devenant ainsi
la première femme conductrice est la
première personne au monde à faire un
long voyage en voiture
parce que oui elle va utiliser le
tricycle benz 1 pour partir avec ses
deux fils voir sa mère à 106 km de là
avec une vitesse de pointe de 15 km à
rennes mais près de douze heures pour
réaliser ce périple en s'arrêtant dans
les pharmacies en chemin pour récupérer
du pétrole les transformant ainsi en
première station service de l'histoire
et c'est donc l'escapade de bertha benz
qui va permettre de faire connaître au
grand public l'invention de son mari et
c'est notamment au cours de ce périple
qui demande maintes réparation qu'alain
vente les plaquettes de frein donc
vraiment là on peut dire gg berta on a
même eu droit à une reconstitution dans
un petit film fait par la marque en 2018
avec les options panneaux de textes
inspirant et espoirs ineffable dans les
yeux d'un enfant et ça vraiment c'est
beau
alors il faut pas s'emballer non plus
parce que des tricycles bengone le
carlito il va en vendre deux en tout et
pour tout donc c'est classe certes mais
pour l'instant il n'y a rien de dingue
dingue dingue c'est pas pour le moment
qu'on va pouvoir
zoom zoom zain dans sa bentley james
bond c'est pas pour tout de suite mais
ça se démocratise quand même assez vite
si on regarde les chiffres de l'insee en
2020 c'est 84,1 % des français de plus
de 16 ans qui possède une automobile
donc autant vous dire que la voiture
s'est diffusée au cours du 20e siècle
aussi rapidement qu'une souche de sart
scholes dans une école primaire quoi
quoi too soon et cette diffusion elle va
notamment être rendues possibles par des
changements dans les modes de production
à savoir par l'organisation scientifique
du travail qu'on appelle aussi le
terrorisme du nom de l'ingénieur fredrik
winslow tyler alors contrairement à ce
qu'on croit souvent il n'a pas inventé
le travail à la chaîne qui existe depuis
bien plus longtemps
il a simplement mis en place une
division horizontale et verticale du
travail qui permet d'améliorer
grandement la productivité mais encore
là toi pour ce qui est de l'automobile
c'est le constructeur henrie ford qui va
faire d'énormes gains de productivité en
appliquant les méthodes du terrorisme à
la production de voitures il construit
notamment entre 1906 et 1927 la fameuse
ford t qui est considéré comme la
première voiture accessible au grand
public
théo compte c'est mon émission on
retient notamment reynerie forte parce
qu'il a fait le choix de bien payer ses
salariés c'est le fameux five tu en as
the day
et oui à l'époque gagné 5 dollars par
jour c'était être carrément mieux
pierrick la moyenne ce qui fut en fait
double effet kiss cool pour ford parce
que non seulement ces employés ont
l'impression d'être bien payé donc il
travaille mieux mais en plus comme ils
ont un plus grand pouvoir d'achat ils
sont capables d'acheter eux-mêmes les
voitures qui passent leurs journées à
produire et donc ça crée de nouveaux
débouchés pour la vente automobile
si vous fait chier vous me le dites je
me faire un café cette organisation du
travail a notamment donné naissance à ce
que les économistes régulationniste
appelle le compromis fordiste c'est une
étape du capitalisme qui dure environ
jusqu'aux années soixante dix où les
forts gains de productivité sont très
largement redistribuer aux travailleurs
ce qui permet donc de stimuler la
demande et donc de garder un marché
ultra dynamique et innovateur stop
mais quoi mais qu'est ce qu'il ya mais
vous n'avez pas l'impression de cartes
jacques hémond émission là un peu bah
oui mais c'est toi qui l'a mise là la
caméra nous on n'a rien fait non mais
oui je sais j'ai essayé plusieurs décors
mais à chaque fois je suis revenue
si vous auriez dû me suivre non tu sais
les procédés narratifs s'est jamais bien
clair de comment ça fonctionne
tu es bien gentil mais moi je veux pas
sortir du cadre regarde ue
on va aller loin comme ça voulait dire
qu'à chaque fois que je vais essayer un
nouveau décor ça me fait un nouveau
perso récurrents alors je voulais pas
vous couper mais moi juste parti me
faire un café et maintenant je peux plus
bouger de la cuisine donc si on pouvait
trouver une solution au problème ça
m'arrangerait je vous avoue que tu as et
pour aussi voilà c'est pas juste nous
faut que tu arrêtes de changer de cadre
comme ça weezy non mais ça ne l'est pas
ça avant faut juste que tu te calmes sur
les déplacements soient plus rapides
plus direct plus concis mais vous êtes
marrant vous déjà que j'ai pas fait de
vidéos depuis longtemps maintenant il
faut plus que je bouge dans leur taille
d'ici sous prétexte de créer des
parasites
ah bah voilà tout de suite les insultes
c'est pas très constructif nous
ont-elles à faire ta vidéo l'arrangement
nous l'a dit pas son nom mais attention
moi le soin de débattre avec lui un
mojito du griot d'achille alors j ai dû
au fait qu on va se calmer mais là vous
allez tous vous délirez l'anus en bons
coups parce que là je suis en train de
faire le montage et c'est d'un bordel
c'est un bordel alors les deux pnj qui
servent à rien là vous fermez bien vous
mouiller jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo et
les autres vous arrêtez de chialer comme
des sarkozystes en jour de jugement et
vous reprenez votre mâchoire sur des
bagnoles là et je vous préviens sans
vous engueuler cette fois
allez on y va du coup c'est surtout
après la deuxième guerre mondiale que la
voiture va progressivement se diffuser à
toute la population
en france c'est surtout le président
georges pompidou qui sera le principal
ambassadeur du tout automobile
il était d'ailleurs lui-même un grand
fan de voitures de sport il a grandement
oeuvré pour la modernisation des routes
françaises
il est d'ailleurs resté célèbre pour une
petite citation bien à propos les
français aiment la bagnole c'est quand
même bien mieux de voiture propre nom à
l'occasion je vous mettrais un petit
coup de polish ça ne suffit pas de
regarder la progression d'équipement
automobile en général pour dire que
toute la population accède à la voiture
parce que justement tout le monde n'y
accède pas en même temps la diffusion de
la voiture elle est d'abord verticale
d'abord les riches
après les prolos mais aussi étonnant que
ça puisse paraître elle est aussi jean
ray hé oui la voiture ça avant tout un
truc de bonhomme ami m'a dit j'ai une
grosse voiture
ouais enfin c'est bien connu les mecs
qui s'achètent des grosses voitures
c'est avant tout pour compenser la
taille de leurs petites buttes aura pas
échappé non plus que la voiture est
d'ailleurs souvent marketé pour les
hommes on en fait une allégorie de la
puissance de la liberté et bien sûr du
pouvoir de séduction il al'argent il a
le pouvoir
il a une audi il a une âme
il aura la femme c'est un petit peu ce
que ce soit quand même su peu pour le
coup les publicitaires ont quand même
tenté des pubs à destination des femmes
mais ils sont assez rapidement retombé
sur des clichés sexistes de type les
salles les femmes savent pas conduire ça
passe garer c'est pourquoi nouvelle
renault twingo vous offre l'option
désolé de m'être garer là des petites
cartes qui vous font passer pour une
fille sympa même quand vous êtes mal
garées mais dis donc mieux mais ça aussi
ça tu peux ce qui est toujours oui mais
si l'aspect publicité autour de la
voiture vous intéresse je vous renvoie
vers la chaîne d'horizon gül qui a fait
une vidéo de près d'une heure sur le
sujet et tout est absolument génial donc
je vous invite très fortement à elle a
consulté ici on va plutôt s'intéresser à
comment s'est faite la diffusion de la
voiture au cours du 20e siècle en
regardant plus précisément les écarts
entre les hommes et les femmes
on s'appuie ici sur un article de 2014
de yoann démoli qu'étudie notamment
comment c'est fait l'accès au permis de
conduire pour les femmes
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a été bien plus tardif que pour
les hommes
et d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément
étonnant quand on s'intéresse au
caractère symbolique des sphères
féminine et masculine
c'est ce que montre notamment pierre
bourdieu dans son livre et la domination
masculine et qui a été développé par de
nombreux autres travaux le masculin et
le féminin sont traversés par des ordres
symbolique en opposition on ou bas
droite ou gauche chaud ou froid
intérieur extérieur calme agitation lune
soleil
john the onion cette mission a créé 1 et
6 1 et dont nos sociétés comme dans
beaucoup de sociétés d'ailleurs la
sphère féminine est associée à la sphère
domestique à l'intérieur à l'immobilité
alors que la masculinité est associé à
l'extérieur au mouvement à la sphère
publique et on retrouve notamment le bon
vieux modèle conservateur de la femme au
foyer et de l'homme brède riner qui
ramène le pain sur la table pour toute
la famille on comprend donc bien que
dans cet ordre symbolique un objet qui
fait tu te poses boom room et qui permet
le mouvement et l'émancipation est
naturellement attribués aux hommes et on
accuse les femmes qui voudraient s'en
emparer de vouloir renverser l'ordre
social
à tel point que dans les années 30 quand
on commence à développer la voiture
électrique parce que oui la voiture
électrique peut être pas d'hier on va
assez naturellement la tribu aux fans
parce que ce sont des voitures qui sont
silencieuses qui font moins de bruit et
qu'on moins d'autonomie aussi donc il
permet d'aller moins loin et donc ça va
être assez naturellement marques étaient
comme des produits davantage féminin et
henri force d'ailleurs offrira une
voiture électrique à sa femme
on retrouve donc dans l'idée que les
femmes ne faut pas trop quelle phase de
bruit et surtout faut pas trop qu'elle
s'éloigne de la maison dans ça peut être
dangereux si elles vont trop loin le
plus drôle dans tout ça c'est que c'est
même pas spécifique à la voiture en fait
on a par exemple l'historien christopher
thompson qui étudie la diffusion de la
bicyclette envers les femmes bourgeoises
de la fin du dix neuvième siècle et ce
qui montre c'est qu'en fait la grande
majorité de la population était
complètement opposés à l'idée que les
femmes puissent aller où elle voulait en
bicyclette bahraoui un ciel ont un peu
de liberté qu'on peut pas contrôler où
elles vont c'est bien connu
elles vont se dévergonder et évidemment
comme les robes longues ou l'écorcé ce
n'était pas le truc le plus pratique
pour faire du vélo
les femmes ont aussi commencé à apporter
de nouveaux vêtements qui se rapprocher
un peu plus du pantalon
alors là autant dire que c'était
carrément la fin du monde pour les
conservateurs au point que tenez vous
bien tenez vous mieux et bien que ce
partenaire technologique de la femme
nouvelle comme ensemble visiblement
appelé les vélos à l'époque et est même
soupçonné de devenir un nouveau
partenaire sexuel ah non mais
l'insécurité masculine a pas de limite
en fait suffit que les femmes acquièrent
un iota liberté et tout de suite on
trouve le moyen de ramener ça le nom met
au point qu'il y a eu de vifs débats en
médecine à l'époque pour déterminer si
l'acte de pédaler pouvait être considéré
comme une forme de masturbation aino qui
conduirait évidemment les femmes à aller
chercher le plaisir sexuel sur leurs
nouvelles machines plutôt que dans le
lit conjugal
ah ben il faut se poser toutes les
questions on sait jamais c'est comme ça
que la science évolue
bon donc vous voyez qu'on revient déjà
de loin avec le vélo donc il faut pas
s'étonner que la voiture ça met un petit
peu de temps à se diffuser aux femmes
mais ça va venir
aller en voiture simone
simone tu sais pourquoi on dit en
voiture simone
moi je pensais que c'était l'expression
de guy lux dans intervilles pour
présenter merci simone d'obtenir un
combat voyez je me rends utile
alors oui non en fait il a popularisé
l'expression parce qu'il employait
souvent pour s'adresser à sa partenaire
simone garnier
mais en fait l'expression est plus
ancienne et elle fait référence à une
autre simone simone de beauvoir nom
simone veil -le non plus l'autre simone
veil toujours pas il y en a eu d'autres
et oui parce que cette expression fait
référence à simone louise de pinède de
bord des forêts une prolos quoi elle est
connue parce qu'elle fut l'une des
premières femmes françaises à obtenir
son permis de conduire en 1829 pas la
première mais une des premières mais
aussi parce qu'elle a participé à des
courses automobiles dès les années 30
et du coup belle expression en voiture
simone aînés parmi ses supporters
d'ailleurs l'expression complète étant
en voiture simone s'étant qui conduit
c'est moi qui klaxonnent et avait prévu
une transition là après ton histoire de
simone où on va juste rester sur un
silence malesan de balle le jeu non
alors depuis simone machin la simone
louise de pin et de bord des forêts
alors je vais l'appeler poète paul
simmons ça tu vas peau de paul simmons
donc depuis poète paul simmons et
surtout en fait depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale la voiture va se
diffuser de plus en plus à la population
féminine est une bonne façon
d'objectiver ça de trouver ça dans les
chiffres ça va être de regarder le taux
d'attribution des permis de conduire aux
femmes et cette augmentation la voie
clairement cours des enquêtes parce
qu'il est environ 22 % des femmes qui
ont leur permis en 1967 et elles sont
plus de 76% dans la dernière enquête de
alors j'ai pas trouvé les données après
2007 mais on voit clairement l'évolution
sur la fin du xxème siècle
mais le plus intéressant c'est quand on
compare cette eau là à ceux des hommes
et vous pouvez voir qu'à toutes les
époques le permis à davantage possédés
par les hommes que par les femmes
il faudra attendre 1993 pour que le taux
de sam ayant le permis à times celui des
hommes de 1967 soit 65% et on voit qu
encore en 2007 on a quand même une
différence de 15 points entre les hommes
et les femmes mais en fait c'est pas
anodin puisque comme le souligne owen
démoli de son article en fait le permis
c'est un titre qui est délivré
par une administration publique c'est
donc un titre qui atteste de compétences
sanctionnées par l'état et du coup ans à
un peu complètement le comparer un
diplôme
il a exactement le même rôle et la même
fonction qu'un diplôme scolaire
il écrit que semblable à un diplôme le
permis à part est exceptionnel en ceci
qu'il est l'un des rares titres à être
davantage possédés par les hommes que
par les femmes
et effectivement depuis la
démocratisation scolaire on observe
qu'en général les femmes ont un niveau
de diplôme plus élevé que celui des
hommes
quand on regarde les derniers chiffres
de l'insee disponibles sur le sujet on
voit que la part de bacheliers ou plus
est bien supérieure dans la population
féminine que dans la population
masculine et ce quel que soit leur âge
pourtant quand on regarde le permis de
conduire on voit que l'écart est
inversée ce qui montre bien qu'il
symbolise quelque chose de très
différent des autres titres scolaires
mais du coup me diriez vous et vous
n'auriez pas tort de le penser
maintenant que les femmes en enfin
gagner l'accès à la voiture et il n'y a
pas de raison que l'écart entre les
hommes et les femmes ne continue pas à
se réduire dans les années à venir
ça veut dire qu'elles ont enfin gagné
l'émancipation permise par la voiture
ouvre une popote tout le monde est
heureux que vous êtes naïf et oui parce
que comme le souligne dans son article
m'a démoli ça ne suffit pas de regarder
le taux d'équipement où le taux
d'obtention du permis de conduire il
faut aussi regarder plus en détail les
usages si on veut vraiment comprendre
les différences de mobilité entre les
hommes et les femmes
alors ce qu'a fait johan démolissez
qu'il s'est servi de l'enquète transport
de l'insee qui contient justement des
données sur les modes de déplacement des
ménages et il a ensuite compilé les
enquêtes 81 93 et 2008 justement pour
pouvoir faire des comparaisons dans le
temps alors pour avoir des données
significatives il n'a gardé que les
personnes actives c'est à dire qu'ils
entendent emploi ou qui cherchent un
emploi parce que étant donné que les
femmes sont plus souvent inactive ou à
temps partiel subi que les hommes
forcément cette donnée aurait impacté
les résultats de déplacements en voiture
alors il commence par faire une
régression il constate une grosse
différence sur le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus entre les hommes et les femmes
toutes choses égales par ailleurs être
une femme plutôt qu'un homme diminue de
3000 km la distance annuels parcourus en
voiture
et si vous vous posez la question oui
j'ai prévu de faire un jour un épisode
sur la régression statistiques et son
usage en sociologie
je sais par contre j'aurai le temps de
faire ça mais c'est prévu par la suite
il va regarder la répartition
hommes-femmes des trajets en voiture en
fonction du type de trajet en quatre
modalités en fonction de cil il s'agit
d'un trajet pour le loisir d'un tragique
pour les sociabilités d'un trajet pour
le travail ou dans le trajet pour le
travail domestique cette fois il en sort
ce tableau là où on voit en bleu et
trajets effectués par les femmes en
orange les trajets effectués par les
hommes et on peut observer les
différentes répartition dans les trois
enquêtes successives 81 93 et 2008 le
premier truc a remarqué c'est donc
évidemment une certaine convergence
alors qu'en 1981 tous les trajets
étaient très majoritairement réalisées
par des hommes
c'est beaucoup plus égalitaire
aujourd'hui par contre on remarque
toujours des différences assez notable
pour le type de trajet tout d'abord les
trajets liés aux loisirs restent
majoritairement masculin on est 1 54% de
ses trajets qui sont faits par des
hommes
mais le plus intéressant ce sont les
trajets liés au travail domestique
puisque c'est le seul trajet pour
lesquelles les femmes sont majoritaires
avec 58 % de ces trajets qui sont
effectuées par des femmes
en fait ce que remarque les sociologues
et lario a démoli s'appuie sur d'autres
enquêtes sur le sujet c'est que l'accès
à la voiture pour les femmes n'est pas
forcément le signe d'une émancipation de
la même façon que l'introduction des
appareils ménagers n'a que peu modifié
le poids et la répartition des tâches
domestiques
ah ouais moulinex libère la femme mon
oeil et bien la voiture a eu pour effet
d'étendre la sphère du travail
domestique plutôt que de permettre aux
femmes de son échappée pas de chance
et oui on pensait que la voiture allait
permettre aux femmes de s'échapper du
carcan domestique et d'accéder à de
nouvelles formes de mobilité jusque là
réservés aux hommes
et si cela était vrai dans une certaine
mesure notamment pour les milieux
favorisés l'usagé de la voiture pour les
femmes ce qu'on donne le plus souvent à
des petits trajets comme aller faire les
courses ou aller chercher les enfants à
l'école qui ne sont que le prolongement
de la sphère domestique à l'extérieur de
la maison pour ces femmes-là l'accès au
permis de conduire ne se caractérise pas
tant par une émancipation que par le
transfert de certains trajets qui était
auparavant réalisées par des hommes à
l'époque où ils étaient les seuls à
avoir le permis et qui leur sont
désormais dévolues et on n'est pas sorti
du sable cet épisode d'associer le quick
est maintenant de terminer j'espère
qu'il vous aura plu il y aurait
énormément de choses à dire en plus
sur la voiture étudiez sociologiquement
j'ai d'ailleurs quasiment pas parlé des
classes sociales il ya pourtant
énormément de choses à dire sur les
usages de la voiture sur la voiture
comme marqueur social ne serait ce que
sur les couleurs de voitures mais voilà
j'ai fait un des épisodes de sociologues
fuite avait longtemps que les pâtes et
ce format là le but de ce format c'est
de rester suffisamment court et concis
donc j'ai décidé plutôt max et sur un
seul sujet à savoir la diffusion de la
voiture aux femmes
n'hésitez pas à me dire aux commentaires
si vous aimeriez que je fasse un
deuxième épisode justement pour traiter
des aspects plus en terme d'inégalités
de classe sociale sur l'appropriation de
la voiture bon juste une petite
parenthèse pour signaler que finalement
c'est pas un l'épisode de socios de
quick mais c'est bien un épisode hors
série que j'ai que j'ai tourné parce que
les pièces de sociologues et les
ancêtres court moins de dix minutes
et à ce moment là quand je suis en train
de tourner je suis absolument persuadé
d'avoir réussi à faire un épisode cours
tu persuadé qu'on est en dessous des 10
minutes là comme quoi entre ce qu'on
écrit est ce qu on tourne on se rend pas
toujours bien content l'idée c'est que
en fait j'ai plein d'idées pour la
chaîne mais que comme c'est des projets
qui sont beaucoup beaucoup trop long à
chaque fois en fait je me retrouve un
petit peu
avec pas le temps de le faire et du coup
je fais rien et j'essaie de me forcer un
petit peu à faire des formats courts
donc forcément je vais pas au fond des
choses mais mais ça permet quand même de
discuter un petit peu d'un sujet donc
évidemment il y aura encore plein de
choses à dire sur le sujet je vous
invite à aller lire le petit repère de
pierre lannoy et one démoli sur le sujet
si ça vous intéresse parce qu'il est
très complet et moi j'espère vous revoir
dans pas trop longtemps et à la
prochaine
[Musique]
yoann démoli genève eu comme prof en
master je me souviens j'avais fait un
exposé sur tocqueville
je veux une note de merde